are you guys on the ground yet I'm on
the ground yes I'm on the ground yeah Oh
Oh what [ __ ] is that thing what is this
thing what are you seeing this [ __ ] look
at the tiny head on this sumbitch no
why's his head so tiny I don't know
markiplier where's the tick hippo what's
happening violent violent
yeah whatever all four guys see where
you are I have a bunch of leaves and
they're not that weight cut they're not
that I want to see what's going on it's
not good what does Cole give me this
Cole tink tink Tong ting Oh wiser more
I'm getting cold though hell yeah watch
it watch it they're really easy to chew
oh I'm gonna zap Marco I do all Marc
mindsets active oh I randomly jumped
over it I killed one
how'd you kill one please wait stop
stick out you can go ahead tab and drag
the thing with dog into your hand
[Music]
oh oh yeah of course I do
yeah did that punch I think I just
punched Michelle Thea's at least three
I'm gonna go do like the game you guys
keep killing that giant and beautiful
creature or whatever I guess all right
cool ain't got [ __ ] is what he got I'm
the nice one mark and Wade are [ __ ]
evil
Bob are you pink yam pig I'm coming to
you we're gonna play this game yeah I
just harvested some iron look up it's a
butterfly maw thing honestly we'd be
crazy man it's a giant thing right here
yeah get the crazy on your eyes get the
crazy out of your eyes hey guys I have
some nuts that heal you half of heel
block oh I've already got some nuts I
can build the hub the heart of our
Factory this is where you complete
fix-it milestones yeah whatever
like we need that I don't think that's
part of the game I like hitting iron
it's so fun yeah no I know
I like the way that the chip wears like
elastic or something it's really cool
clay can we play the games
I feel like 30 irons is a good amount of
iron
I've got 99 baby nicely done my friend
thank you my friend
my pleasure my friend you're welcome my
friend oh this is a good spot
I built a hub all right cool what I had
a whole spot picked out good job [ __ ]
ignoring me good job
I like your Spock is a terrible place we
should definitely tear this place down
and I'm on the way where are you guys we
are up by the iron that we found okay be
right there do you like where I place
this home it was the first place that it
let me place it yeah nice good job buddy
good job
I really tried to think it out I was
like man what would my friend not want
me to do like this you know this is a
really sick place to start Wade I really
got to commend you you've got an eye you
got an eye football place literally
anywhere else but I was like you know
what would Wade - no yeah nobody you got
this I think you got this huh iron ingot
okay crap great one we need iron ten
iron rods okay so I'm gonna upgrade the
hub I'm gonna make ten iron rods and I'm
gonna upgrade it correct is occupied bro
there were two sides to it I thought
that was it that's fine all right
do we only want one hopper do we want
multiple hubs I don't know oh yeah okay
I'm gonna do this boom upgrade oh nice
nice three I'm stopping there because
you upgraded yeah
now I can do stuff biomass burner I'm
gonna burn some leaves I'm burning
leaves why are you burning leaves if
it's not connected to anything I just
wanna burn some leaves
I mean eco-terrorists all right I'm
putting all my leaves in there it's
maxed out of 500 leaves cool man I'm
gathering more leaves though just in
case so hub upgrade - we need 10 plates
10 rods and wire 50y I can I can make
the plates in the roads up this way up
north I'm coming for you wait listen
let's take this together all right
oh that's nice well six at a time
Oh fill me did he yeah didn't you know
that this is how this works no I've not
seen one of these only had a little baby
one and and normal ones give you two at
a time so you could just mine this
forever oh maybe not forever I don't
know maybe not forever you got you bit
just getting some copper over there Oh
copper oh did you all crash no no I'm
still here
oh wait there you are are you back in no
my games relaunching oh but your body's
here a lot of weird me probably enough
copper to get started someone head back
to the home I got enough for wire so I'm
gonna make this B wire okay I'm here
hello okay you want me to go ahead for
this Bob go for it don't can upgrade
wait let me get a look at you hey Anna
face me here oh yeah I'm not gonna look
at you either really you have a space
helmet and you're kind of orange and
khaki colored uh-huh you two you two do
I look like Bob to you you guys look the
same to me yeah
Oh God we're all the same we get for not
investing and more expensive
customization on what are you doing on
this what are you doing Bob I'm looking
at the things we I want to make a
smelter oh I have a will to make a
smelter which says when did I have a
builder well you sort of have one yes I
want to make a smelter power poles and
power a lot guys we're in trouble
I'm not the focus oh [ __ ] I don't have
what we need do you guys have what we
need to make a smelter I need a wire at
the rock but I need wire I can make I
can make lots of wire yeah I'm
as soon as you're done yes we need more
crafts we each need our own craft bench
I think yeah I just need three plate
three rod per craft beds so it's yeah I
just need I just need some plates and I
can build my own craft bench actually we
use this real quick really wait get out
of there I just finished converting all
the copper into ingots stupid I've got
everything I need to make a crafty thing
I'm gonna make my own I'm gonna keep
this one and as my own I'm gonna make my
own craft bench with a view oh I see the
giant butterfly oh yeah there's one Bob
guys look at my craft bed dude that's a
sick craft bench right this [ __ ]
Wow I don't see the butterfly moth that
is so cool I'm gonna build mine right
here next to yours you could just look
backwards that's our biomass burner
are you a snail god oh do I worship you
what are we talking about a freaking
weirdo what in the world are you saying
I found the snail god no this still
doesn't answer anything come over here
there's a glowing green snail God on top
of this rock in front of there's a glow
okay you expect me to believe there's a
glowing green snail God on top of a rock
well if you don't believe me I told you
literally where I'm at so you could come
see it you see the glory no I don't see
the glowing green snail electricity oh
yeah big whoop Thomas Edison did that a
long time ago oh you're so special
powers what are you talking about this
what what do you see it no no
interesting I've got it ooh okay okay
okay Wade whatever you say chat says
harvest the power slug whatever that
means yeah I did I've got it in my
inventory Bob I can confirm I saw
nothing so I think Wade is losing it I
think we should probably losing
we should probably kill him straight up
just because he's already lost his mom
all right so can we build any sort of
automatic mining equipment yet how do we
do that
I don't think so I think we're manual
for a little bit longer yeah Bob you
hold down the fort I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep exploring for more rare minerals
and stuff we need concrete how do we
make convex crashing guys my game
crushed that that seems to be a regular
thing build constructors to automate
production of simple parts build power
poles to extend your power grid expand
your production to upgrade faster it
really is like factorial are we gonna
have to fight aliens and we already have
no I mean like for real aliens that's
what I liked about factorials yeah I
think all these fake aliens you shut
your mouth you shut you shut your
gosh-darn mouth did you get food
delivery what we're doing gaming chica
got her birthday chicken oh nice oh is
that why you said yeah it wasn't to Bob
to hang oddly enough no I hope there are
air horns at my funeral really if I live
yeah I got your back I hope you live to
be pretty old though because I cannot
imagine your acting well if I show up to
playing air horns well my mom would be
recording it to be perfectly my mom
would record my own that surgery on your
scar tissue your mom was like the doctor
like dr. you do a good job I gotta eat
my chicken I found a cave I'm gonna go
in the cave but only after I eat my
chicken plates and reinforced iron plate
I'm making the reinforced iron plates
right now okay mark give us a sweet iron
plates but I'll be there and just the
[ __ ] are you and a cave exploring it's
weird this snails everywhere there's a
red power lizard I can't believe I'm so
lucky I can't believe the shut up last
one in existence who'da thunk my green
that power slug is in this box there's
proof that it exists in that box I don't
I don't see what you're talking about
I'm almost done with the hub upgrade
you're welcome I'm almost done exploring
this cave there's all kinds of colored
creatures it's like a skittles
commercial in here there's so many
collar schools sunrise sunrise good view
you have a good view yeah from my
workbench that's right where how would I
have known it would be turned around
save the slugs they're important later I
ain't the slug but that was my slug god
I your God who's God now they seen the
sunrise mark it's beautiful yeah I'm in
cave but a window got a window it's got
like just legs is your power lizard
create a window so you could observe the
beautiful sunrise wait there's green
oh it's healing there's healing gas here
I'm not gonna lie I was not in the cave
before I am now in the cave flyer I get
mushrooms you found glue fungus hi I
found white sticky glue in this cave
dude how's it taste a little salty
little salty but you know it's not as
amazing it's not too bad I like the
flavor it's got a tang to it
mm mm mm real good real good that
Stavros like the way you say oh my god
[Laughter]
in the cave by the way care what you're
fighting holy [ __ ] there's a Death Star
okay well I'm gonna upgrade the hub
cause I'm doing stuff what does that
mean things I'm doing stuff know the
gravitational radiation sphere what is
that hiding who's hiding hey guys I
upgraded the hub how are you doing all
pop they're chasing me we're gonna have
some fun
you can come up on top oh I see you hey
how's it going yeah they turned left
fire do they now they spit fire like a
Death Star
that sounds so believable I they spit
fire I
stole their Death Star's oh you stole
their Death Star yeah okay all right I
harvested the Death Star and it gave me
a Mercer beer Wow Wow
you harvested the Death Star you see how
I just don't believe a word you're
saying I'm gonna heal up cuz I almost
died yeah yeah yeah big baby Oh God
really this thing's not even in game yet
it says a weird alien thing with an
impossibly smooth surface work in
progress
analyzing will not give you anything
[ __ ] I'm getting so much wine guys
my inventory is full I didn't know that
could happen
yeah I'm number of spaces I have in mind
that it could be filled I don't like
your attitude there friend guys there's
a green power slug here oh my god mark
did you find a green power slow yeah
it's weird it looks like a slug but as
green and crystalline it's glowing
that's crazy man I'm gonna pick it up
actually hate you I went in that cave
and I came out someplace I was way
farther away where are you guys oh [ __ ]
I got so far oh [ __ ] your best friends
back and you're gonna be in trouble oh
no these are directional oh [ __ ] oh you
goofed it oh I came here just in time to
see you mess up I goofed guys I goofed I
see that alright mark mark I need to
take you somewhere I'm busy what do you
need what's up buddy what's up friend
come on a fun trip with me okay I don't
wanna but here I go I got a lot of stuff
in my inventory I kind of want to drop
it off first day I'm not gonna go yet
hey I got a drop yourself definitely go
before you draw are you definitely drop
off before we go I'm gonna drop off I'm
doing that right now that's like the
smartest thing you've ever done in a
game really I'm not saying like you're
usually dumb in games but like hey man
look at you thanks man thank you proof
that evolution is real whoa we just just
proved right here lies I made a conveyor
thing oh wow good job Bob okay wait
what's up order thing all right come
with me well there's a tick thing up
here this doesn't do anything but I made
a conveyor belt okay there's some cool
stuff right here whoa whoa whoa whoa all
right I'm heading back to see Bob's
gonna kill him I'm gonna kill me huh Wow
I'm gonna kill him I'm gonna kill him
oh ho God they hurt
so thoroughly well I just wanted you to
suffer for questioning me I use
something wait show you so I swear to
God if you drop your pants again I will
not be oh why don't we just go to the
cave nearby for a little second here I
don't like the way you said cave nearby
I'm just describing where it is and what
we need to do we need to go in the cave
nearby whoa what the hell I'm doing
stuff alright I'm doing actual things we
are to man we doing that's you wait
sound like that you says what you should
you both sound like that to me so it's
fine like this look guys I did it you
did it you did what oh that's nice miner
[ __ ] yeah what do I need cable [ __ ] yes
gallery here alright I can make cable
how do I need like three of those I can
make one I'm gonna make one I wanna know
if it works I mean it I'm gonna place it
from a place it where is it here it is
go use my go use my conveyor belt
alright cool here I go and pop that
there all right it's tiny
it's so small you have to provide power
ok you know it's getting bigger we have
power we got power
look at it go that far Wow
dude it's so cool how do you like
connect your ear importable minor I
don't know if these are capable of these
don't go onto the barrier belts but I
want them to I just want something to go
into the smelter goddammit look now
sometimes food do you have miner you
need a miner mark one to use the
goddammit nerd actually I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna live my life like this
hang on I'm building us some ramps okay
I'm not a goddamn Club which prime
gusting human I don't know have you
heard of twins only calm because they
just dated five dollars these things
make so much iron oh [ __ ] yeah where was
a copper thing nearby right yeah we
should put up we should make a copper
I'm gonna go I made your shoe number
yeah I'll go get going on the limestone
okay all right yeah blank and then how
many how many portable miners could you
put on these things it seems like a lot
I don't know how many we need oh I need
copper [ __ ] I need here here here take
it take it take it all very capacious
copper I'll be right I'm gonna go to
limestone do we need lime sir for
anything because I got limestone i
deeper deeper when I have food stuck in
my throat I don't understand that oh my
god this is so much copper we need more
come I'm gonna come to you mark and I'm
gonna I'm gonna put my two thingies on
copper don't take any fuel or any power
to operate they just not I just do it
hell yeah man oh god damn it
Wade's only calm yeah hold your weight
[ __ ] needs go to Wade's only talk
wait [ __ ] I'm gonna work on trying to
get the next upgrade going okay what do
you need for that I can bring back a
bunch of limestone concrete which i
think is from limestone should be still
in the chest I got plenty I got more
than enough I don't need yours how about
you go away dick you glad that we're
working together on this Wade's only
calm if you want to eat that way dick
for the next hub upgrade that's what I'm
working on
we need ayran I'm smelting a hundred
iron ore in the smelter right now should
be done iron plates iron rod I've got
the concrete taken care of oh this
thing's overheating oh [ __ ] it's about
to blow it this shit's about to blow
what is I don't off crafting too much
red hot it's red hot what oh it's fine
no mark this being hot dumb it's gonna
it's fine marks just an idiot non-stop
diarrhea thank you for
the bids I'm gonna hunt you on it mute
well I guess you guys need to hear but
my non-stop I thought you were decided
about how you have non stop that was a
donation mark you care fine it's just I
thought it was gonna blow and it's
waiting for the inevitable end you know
the sweet embrace of death to come claim
me but it never did so I guess we're
fine just like her it never came but we
come together talk my favorite Oh
apparently you can build conveyors to
storage containers son now that is what
I am talking about yes this is some
factorio [ __ ] right now
where's my inserters I want to shove
things inside wait there's the rod it
needs like 70 plates more and then we're
there all right I can make like 55 go
for it and do it I'll put those that is
something you're something you're really
something wait why are we stop it I was
company I was complimenting him be nice
what all the beamers really shown seven
more iron plates what is happening in my
chat right now grades gonna be done
right now yeah it should be yeah put the
plates in there Bob climb up on this
thing if you're here why if we look on
the east of us there's like something up
there oh there is something up there
look at that there is something up there
there really is I think that's Southeast
to it was wanted to see what would
happen I don't know the thing made me al
[ __ ] that seems just wanted to be king
of the mountain we can make a storage
container now nice [ __ ] yes storage
container minor
you want mark 1 yes it's it's just rods
and concrete plus a plus a minor thing
is all you need for that oh god no I can
do it you want me to do it yeah I guess
craft it can we get these little ones
out of the way okay here's an important
question how do I rotate this mouse
scroll wheel scroll wheel ah I see I see
I see
can we not we should be able to pick
those up I think I want to pick up my
nerf got it god I gotta get which which
way this thing's way bigger than I
suspected is the green box I think is
the output mark so you want to output it
told you you can't see what I'm
previewing right ok this it's just this
can you see this conveyor belt right
here yeah I do like this that's the only
valid way that'll let me put it right
yeah we can we can wrap the conveyor
belt okay cool alright here we go ready
yeah I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do the
conveyor and I'm just gonna like wrap it
around I shouldn't read that one
probably read it you know how like when
your mind in it and it's spelled mi n ER
right yeah so only miners dot-com
spelled like that and the quote was why
is everyone so mad about our dating
service only miners dot Oh God why did
you read that you told me to know why
did you read that build a power pole
because I think it needs to connect you
have to also build like the other thing
what you call it power line why is this
not connecting why is this not working
why can I know what the [ __ ] won't
connect why won't it connect it's not
giving me an error code on why it won't
connect no power Oh are you trying to do
power yes I'm trying to do power yes I'm
trying there what did that one connect
here okay I had to turn the other buyer
biomass reactor on apparently the
biomass reactor can only go to one thing
it
I'm I think the problem is I think I
know what the problem is let me let me
disassemble this okay oh did I should I
not have Kurt connected the biomass
directly to the okay although vegetable
and then pull to the biomass yeah that's
what exactly what I'm doing yeah look at
these chunks of rock or iron is the word
yeah I do
ohyou storing oh god Bobby open the
storage container you can put so much in
there man all right wait how you doing
Lee [ __ ] I'm reading websites that I
wish I didn't mark I think we've won at
the game I think we won yeah okay so now
that we've beaten the game what do we do
next to feast
mark sockets I already sucked it I'm
good do you want to get the limestone
thing we're going to try get the copper
up next buy copper the coppers are
probably full so what do you need to
make pull I just pulled the copper miner
mark one unique copper source also are
we worried at all that this all might
attract something to attack us what are
we gonna make a gun how do we we can't
even make a gun yet yeah that's that's
true that is true that seems true I will
make sure to watch out for the monsters
for a few minutes here okay thanks Wade
thanks thanks buddy I am here to aid its
Marcus in the goddamn cave and eat for
ten minutes I wasn't even in the cave
hey I've already got all the concrete
submitted for our next up
of our base I did stuff I'm the
limestone guys what they call me in
school they're like hey limestone guys
like that's me limestone guy
what grade what grade did they call the
you that will shock you doctors hated my
thing is glowing so bright I can't see
the button or the lights anymore
it's Sun I think it's gonna blow up dude
if you saw what I'm looking at right now
there's no book oh my god I have so much
copper right now I'm also mine mine is
glowing it's happening hundred wire for
the hub upgrade right now I have 357
wire I'm gonna drop it by your feet so
you can go upgrade that night I really
wish I had a view on this if you like
the amount of concrete I have produced
would you would you ask me that right
now well go to concrete [ __ ] calm and
you can find out one can already see
that you're a huge failure so I don't
know what you're afraid of I've got both
success that's what my mom tells me
you're very famous that's what your mom
tells you who is judging me well I mean
me all the time but I know I made
concrete I'm hopeful did you drop for
extra miners back on the other no you
did
oh I have them in me sorry do you want
me to put them in the storage box
there's another iron deposit right next
to the one buyer base there's toaster
yeah yeah I'll just put them yeah I'll
just put them all I'm gonna plop them
over there give them a good ol plop
there you go I'm gonna steal one of them
just yeah that's fine I may
a minor mark one over on the on the
copper deposit actually we don't have
anything mining copper right now because
I sort of thought I was gonna be able to
finish that because I'm an idiot oh you
want me to put oh wait there's one over
there
he needs there's a minor mark one on the
copper but it needs power and then it
needs like a conveyor belt or whatever
right right okay can we have two
conveyor belts going into the same
smelter I just have it bout to find out
yeah that sounds that sounds cool too
because then we don't have to worry
about as much power over there oh [ __ ] I
need concrete wait I need you for the
first time in forever I need you in
storage 25 concrete on kool aid I'm
grabbing Wade's custom-made handcrafted
delicious
good for you non-gmo non-gmo concrete
that's the best [ __ ] I don't think I can
convey this into the same one oh can I
do this does it do like a connection no
it's kind of wonky okay I want to go to
the same one let's just double irony
into this yeah double irony yeah yeah I
think this is working and look now let
me hook up the power do it so good I'm
gonna do it for you for you powering up
oh that's a that's a big grindy he's a
grandiy boy it looks like these
conveyors match up but I'm not a hundred
percent sure come on baby come on
come on baby come on there's some
biomass in storage I'm just gonna pop it
in there I'm gonna build another smelter
right next to this thing there's got to
be a way that you can combine conveyors
right that seems to be a better way he's
got to be I'm in factorial there was a
specific conveyer belt that would merge
them maybe we have to unlock that
specific part oh you get it later okay
you get it later our I'll just make it
that's like a sorting gate or something
yeah probably
alright I'll just make another smelter
it's fine
okay so we just into conveyor belt and
I'm gonna build you another storage for
your second thing mark wait why is this
conveyor not connecting up it's not
amazing that's not as you need to
upgrade your definition of amazing if
that's what you think amazing is that
don't I don't have enough [ __ ] I need
more [ __ ] you concrete concrete I got
whole jar storage got it okay a right
direction yes oh you're [ __ ] I was
doing that you're good oh I'm sure go
for it go then go then go why don't you
I am go oh I like that placement oh you
can line them up oh [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
line them up so they're lined up
together yes
oh that if you hold left control while
you're lining [ __ ] up you can line them
up oh okay lined up that just lined up
Marc loved it actually and in fact I
think I love it even more that I knew
I'm gonna make another batch of concrete
special sauce what when I just wanted to
go over here be away from you guys for a
kind of problem with ya what's up what's
the deal I know everything's um what's
right what's the problem alright hub
upgrades douche oh [ __ ] this power line
can go on for a long time I didn't how
big is your power line big space
elevator
that's a casual unlock equipment bacon
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man we got bacon in here now
hell yeah damn alright construct or
crafts one part into another can be
automated by feeding parts into it with
conveyor belt connected also we could
yet but I'm gonna we blew a fuse
by the way [ __ ] we're blowing a fuse I
probably won't you do oh god I hooked up
the power let me let me hang out I'll
use the other there's so many power
listen what's wrong with you how'd you
fix that I and I just I got I have to
make a separate power line that goes out
from the other reactor that's all that's
all that's no I see I see what he's
doing this thing says no power are we
out of juice I shouldn't be and what's
the wires I'm hooked up correctly which
they might not be it's connected all the
way from the miner down to the second
generator but the second generator oh
the second generator is not a biomass oh
that would explain it it's like down on
power do we auto harvest biomass to put
in there yeah that would be convenient
if we can harvest biomass from time I
don't know how we do that maybe we could
just throw like the big sea urchin thing
in there and just like have it mastered
the power lizard on it and see what
happens
yeah wait what about these power slugs I
don't know huh I've got one why wouldn't
I acknowledge assume everybody knows
about the power lizards if the span of
these wires too long maybe yeah oh it
says we blew a fuse okay I I know how I
know how I did I know I don't
I don't know I'm gonna do it no it's my
secret series and I have value in this
place okay here's where I think there's
a problem we might have a bug because it
overloaded and then I deconstructed the
thing so so it might be stuck as a blown
fuse so what if we just get rid of the
whole power line and then just build a
new power line much it's like Salvage
Salvage all these power lines and then
build a new line out here to this thing
yeah I'm gonna do that you might as well
just rebuild the whole duder the whole
miner yeah just in case I can analyze my
slug I found a way to use my slope oh
okay I'm building a new power line I've
got a pair belt set up so the miners
ready to go over here on the longest
never mind that power line goes [ __ ] she
runnin runnin alright
oh she's running oh she's worse the
Moose cube guys we've been doing this
all wrong
yeah you stupid idiot alright so it's
producing copper oh yeah oh yeah look at
that go we need we need a smelter [ __ ] I
don't have magical moose moose cube we
can kind of bypass shut you're crazy for
one goddamn second there we go you know
I like the cut of this jib yeah this is
so satisfying in a deeply sexual way oh
my god so we can conveyor belt the
copper out of this storage into another
crafter oh yeah we should try that
constructor do you have what you need to
make a constructor I do actually
right oh yes there nice nice nice I'm
gonna conveyor belt that [ __ ] okay and
then I'll just say to build wire right
yeah and then we just run do we need
another storage unit I guess I guess the
first storage unit but whatever is fine
well we do the only thing copper plates
are good for wire than decay
but right now yeah oh look at it go oh
my god oh yeah you know this is this is
real nice
this is it so it's almost a one-to-one
if you look at the container with the
ingots oh you're definitely a little a
little bit faster constructing that it
is in getting oh yeah eventually we will
get splitter we'll get to smelt oh yeah
this is amazing I like this a lot of
this and I just want to say I'm proud of
you guys for your probe you shion's as
well look at all that goddamn copper
wiring some concrete the man the man all
hail the mam and then Alice's little
green power slug is completed please
choose a new specimen in the list to
begin a new analysis wait I've got it
I've got a new green slug I'm gonna drop
this slug on the ground the slug doesn't
do anything with mam now now it does
something some Oh where's the slug I
dropped it on the ground mark where's
the slug uh I dropped it mark find the
mark those things are like special or
something where's the slide I dropped it
on the ground I dropped it on the ground
I dropped out of it I don't know what
you want me to say I dropped it on the
ground you [ __ ] us no I didn't lose
the slug it just I dropped it on the
ground mark why you do this Pete lost
two slugs no you just gotta find it what
do you think I lost I didn't lose it you
just gotta find it I don't believe you
what I dropped it on the ground it's not
my fault
ooh what's it gonna Mitch on the roof
[Laughter]
I'm overloading this yeah you blew a
fuse
yeah that's not helping I feel like our
wiring looks a little bad so we need
more powers all we need do we need
another yeah yeah we should be able to
build yeah we can oh we can build a
bigger one oh no it's the same never
mind it's the same never ceasing I'm
gonna build one of these just off to the
right here I guess what is this it's a
foundation why do we have it because I
want things to look nice dude Oh mark
you said oh we can do a biomass burner
is that what you're trying to do you
that I just wanted to make a nice
platform for it I'm gonna make you the
rods you need no I'm good I actually
have oh do you have everything I try to
keep a lot of good stuff on me yeah I
try I try this smelter the closer
smelter to you mark is the only one that
needs power right now we still have
upgrade to do with the main base by the
way on if you guys saw that yeah yeah
yeah yeah whatever Wade I think the next
thing we really need to figure out is
how to get biomass effectively if we're
gonna be doing biomass burning for our
power we need just like a way to harvest
that [ __ ] you you right you right
wait what about that green poisonous gas
and what if we just a gas
oh yeah harvest that [ __ ] wait just go
stand in it and soak some of it in and
bring it back you know I was trying to
offer possible constructive ideas and so
was Bob and so was my feel like
murdering me bro that idea right back in
my face murdering me murder really
you're gonna be that hyperbolic
murdering okay whatever yeah yeah it
would never commit an IRL BR on you Wade
why did you just put regular leaves no
no no no no I did that what of it
what of it you two will make them into
biomass no no no you make wood into
biomass you make leaves also into bio I
didn't know that what am I gonna do with
these mushrooms that I got like forever
ago someday you'll have mushroom love oh
it's for biomass there's a toilet here
I'm gonna take a [ __ ] hello [ __ ] I don't
know if I can now I
go I'm in I want to watch over you make
sure you're safe no sea slugs gonna
climb up from the toilets you know we
take this suit off it's kind of tough to
unzip yeah yeah man let me get some
music just to set the mood okay that's
weird thing to do but what did you need
it's fine I'm solving my own problems
[Music]
I've got some I've got samples I've got
samples I gotta get out there we go oh
god [ __ ] you I always going to do that
alright Bob what you need what did you
not working and it said why is it not
working
hello it's yellow may because it doesn't
have any iron in it because the smelter
isn't working anymore
oh why isn't the smelting work I think
it has to go into storage first I think
it does the smelters back on oh never
mind there goes okay do things all right
now it's producing now it's producing I
solved it I'm an idiot don't let me
touch things or you're a genius or
you're a genius iron plates now we just
need to make another one for the iron
rods and we're good to go right we can
switch this one back and forth but yeah
I mean it's whatever I mean why not
right why not we're just we're just
sucking this planet dry you don't know
baby yeah suck it dry we want to convert
this other one into wires oh yes no we
need ingots
these are ingots yeah well this this one
is ingots so we have a lot of ingots
ingots oh sorry rods weenie brats
we need rods what how can I make myself
more clear we need rods so I'm gonna I'm
gonna empty the storage and then break
it down and then do the same sort that's
pretty good yeah you do that but do it
later sexually yeah you're pretty close
this is a problem no the other
constructor how big a problem yeah
that's Cataclysm a medium amount of boy
[Music]
gusting iron plates calm are you looking
for hot smelters in your yeah we're
learning by trial and error learning are
we learning good this is how you play
games right you learn as you go along
and no one yells at you from a distance
the way you play games is you play the
game and try and have fun and like a
thousand people are like your games is
fun there we go now we have a rod
production as well hell yeah
oh look at these rods I'm so happy
production right now I'm so happy about
that
okay so we got the rods we got the
plates
uh-huh we have the copper making wire so
now we just need to get cables going up
and you get two limestone I got cables i
got cables cables are on the way we get
the limestone up and going there's a
limestone deposit west but it's down the
hill right here so Bob do you know where
this limestone is right here no marks on
the only one that's been going over
there oh you're at it oh that's
limestone okay okay that's not just
conveyor that we could just run power
down here yeah you idiot Wade you were
making it seem like a big issue I said
if we wanted it to deliver up there we'd
have to
man this is closer than the copper is
[ __ ] yeah mine was really you dummy
you unbelievable prick Lord okay can you
make that can you make the minor than
wood minor mark 1 yep that's the one
okay on you by the way
so orient the green thing towards like
me what are you missing wait oh my God
he's gonna trample us this is our
limestone you [ __ ]
terrifying tick monster was like
standing right at the output oh Jesus oh
this guy's so big he's so unhappy what
did you do to him I just shocked him in
the dick a little was a bit there you go
get out of here there he goes you guys
are mean we just need power now power
incoming I have I can build this oh can
I have some kind no you have it oh I do
have concrete hey where you want it
never mind boink
got it now damn it I got it you suck you
suck you you suck you suck you suck you
suck you suck you suck you suck you suck
you suck you suck you suck you suck you
suck you solutions
[Laughter]
[Music]
or whatever I'm just gonna make some
useful stuff while you all sit on your
dick
what do you mean we now I just made a
concrete factory love that Wow good for
all the concrete that we need yeah okay
a lot of concrete why there are some
concrete evidence that we will need more
concrete a shot I hate you
that makes it marginally better for all
of your sweet concrete needs go to
concrete lovers dot-com and then just
[ __ ] to your heart's content
what are you doing alright we need 10
alien carapace so Teresa flee what do
you mean was he doing doing dancing the
game more than either of us is advancing
the game I'm working I'm do you suck
you suck you suck you suck I have my
cilia why I need it put in the storage
box
hang on no I need to finish something
launch pod wait what the [ __ ] is this
big red button guys is it new [ __ ]
there's a big red button what do I do
with it loser place for me to get in it
because I want to be in it yeah look for
something like a launch pod also Bob you
know yeah fine whatever
yeah no I know no I'm pressing it here
we go I spent the past hour I spent the
past hour
oh I spent the past hour push getting
all the parts
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you